Xbox Series X was reportedly supposed to
launch in August you can pet the cat in
cyberpunk 2077 and during play for all
we sat down with Red Dead Redemption to
voice actors to go over a bunch of
missions that got cut i'm persia and
you've reach your save state for tuesday
june thirtieth next-gen consoles will be
hidden our homes this holiday season but
some reports assume that microsoft
wanted to get going a lot sooner than
that Brad Sam's reporting for thourough
says Microsoft wanted to launch the
series X this August
furthermore the lockhardt version of the
console the room raid less powerful less
expensive model was then planned to
launch in mid-october
now the lockhardt is expected to be
announced in August and the series X is
obviously launching this holiday this is
just one of many ways that Microsoft has
had to adapt with the current climate of
no e3 and no live events they've been
putting on live streams to give us
gameplay and give us announcements and
the next one's coming up this July so
where do you guys hoping to see next
cyberpunk 2077 previews are out now and
while we're learning a bunch of new
details one very important one has been
confirmed you can pet the cat
while can you pet the dog has been an
important question in video game
criticism inspired by the Twitter
account of the same name cats are now
I'm getting more of the same kind of
recognition in virtual petting we
haven't really heard much about dogs
being able to be pet in the game but
we're often pet cats in The Witcher so
this is definitely a step up if you're
looking for even more information on
cyber point 2077 previews then
definitely check out gamespot.com
tomorrow even has an awesome piece up
about some of the side stories that are
smaller but just as impactful as the
main ones gonna be we already know that
about five hours of content was cut from
Red Dead Redemption too but during our
play for all streaming with some of the
voice actors behind the game we got a
little bit more insight on what exactly
didn't make it
Arthur morgan actor Roger Clark said
Rockstar decided to cut one mission
involving Arthur in Dutch we don't
really know the full context of the
scene but Clark said it involved an
action sequence a train and then taking
out a couple of Boston bounty hunters of
course if you want to see that full
interview then you can check it out on
gamespot.com and of course if you don't
know what play for all is well you're
about to find out
it is our multi week charity event that
we have been hosting all summer long and
still going strong to raise money for
black lives matter and kovat 19 relief
efforts thanks to you guys we've already
raised thousands of dollars and we've
seen amazing game reveals we've played
games with our friends across the
industry and there's still more to come
if you haven't had a chance to tune in
yet well you can check out our entire
schedule of what's still on the way on
gamespot.com
i'm persia and you can follow me on
twitter at persia underscore x oh it's
gonna wrap it up for our news for today
but I hope you reach your next save
state to learn with Kurt I'll see you
guys next time
[Music]